[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas los ataques rusos
continúan devastando a Ucrania con daños
particularmente graves en la red
eléctrica del país lo que supone un
grave riesgo humanitario de Cara a un
invierno que se anuncia como
posiblemente el más difícil en la
historia de la nación gersón fue la
primera y la única gran ciudad de
provincia que cayó en manos enemigas
desde el comienzo de la invasión y la
presión de las fuerzas ucranianas llevó
a que a principios de noviembre las
tropas rusas se retiraran de esa urbe y
ahora se ubican del otro lado del río
nieper desde donde continúan atacando
constantemente eso ha llevado a que
miles de personas abandonen la ciudad
por temor a nuevas embestidas de las
tropas de Moscú informe de nuestra
enviada especial Catalina Gómez Ángel
la presión ucraniana hizo que las
fuerzas rusas abandonaran gersón pero la
población paga por ello han quedado sin
energía eléctrica y sin agua a puertas
de un invierno que ya se siente con
intensidad
mi calefacción trabaja con electricidad
y no hay electricidad qué hacemos
estos puntos de recarga eléctrica son la
única alternativa de la población que
busca restablecer la comunicación con el
mundo exterior durante meses estuvieron
completamente aislados del resto de
Ucrania
la gente más cercana a mí se fue no
podía llamarlos Pero eso no importa
los que se quedaron intento a retomar su
vida como pueden como Iliana que lleva
todos estos meses apoyando a personas
mayores que necesitan de ayuda para
sobrevivir
ellas no pueden hacer nada por su cuenta
Así que desde la mañana hasta la noche
tenemos trabajo
esta mañana le trae una caja con ayuda
humanitaria Sofía una doctora en
biología de 93 años
no electricidad no agua no calefacción
hace frío pero vengo todos los días a
cocinarle algo y lavar
Sofía pasó la mayor parte de la invasión
en este sillón durante meses la radio
dejó de sonar y su única compañía era la
lectura de algunos periódicos viejos
ahora mismo No es fácil es miedoso pero
tengo fortaleza
en la estación cientos de personas han
decidido dejar la ciudad en los últimos
días
las autoridades los han invitado a
abandonar Durante los meses de invierno
pero la mayoría los que llegan hasta
aquí No lo hacen motivados por el temor
al frío Si no los ataques rusos que sean
intensificados estamos muy preocupados
tenemos pesar no queremos irnos porque
es nuestra tierra nuestra casa Esperamos
que sea por poco tiempo los chicos harán
su trabajo y regresaremos a casa con el
paso de los días en gersón aumenta la
expectativa sobre el destino que le
espera a la ciudad
en Líbano los depositantes continúan
tomando justicia por mano propia para
reclamar su dinero que ha sido retenido
por las instituciones financieras desde
hace tres años mientras crece la ira en
las calles por la inacción de la clase
política para establecer un plan de
recuperación concreto muchos están ahora
buscando alternativas en las
criptomonedas ante la retención de sus
fondos en las cuentas bancarias informe
de telgonet y Diego Ibarra
Este no es como esta se repiten
habitualmente los bancos libaneses ante
la desesperación de los depositantes de
no poder disponer de sus ahorros el 4 de
octubre la diputada Cintia zarazir tuvo
que recurrir a la fuerza para retirar su
dinero retenido necesario para pagar un
tratamiento médico se encerró con su
cómplice la abogada de inabuzón en la
oficina bancaria hasta que obtuvo la
suma para los gastos médicos no nos
dejan otra opción No me arrepiento de lo
que hicimos fue un acto de humanidad
Cynthia padece una enfermedad Crónica y
por fin ha sido operada y se está
recuperando mientras la no cambia
seguirá habiendo más allanamientos el
bufete de abogados de Rafi grazi
defiende los derechos legales de los
depositantes y ahorradores libaneses
nuestros ahorros están atrapados desde
hace tres años en los bancos no hay una
visión o estrategia para la recuperación
económica del Líbano es una reacción
natural la gente quiere su dinero los de
baneses no ven mejoría en la situación
económica ahora que el parlamento
libanés intenta pasar una controvertida
ley de control de capitales la ira de
los depositantes crece en las calles
Richard faraón tenía la mayor productora
de eventos en el Líbano
el capital controla no vamos a dejar que
la ley de control de capitales sea
aprobada nuestros gobernantes quieren
acabar con nosotros matar la economía
destruir el país el correcto impuesto
por los bancos que limita el retiro de
efectivo a 100 dólares semanales sumado
al cierre indefinido de las sucursales
bancarias tras la ola de asaltos ha
llevado a cada vez más libaneses a
recurrir a la criptomoneda para poder
pagar sus compras y recibir remesas
extranjeras
nosotros damos una alternativa confiable
a la gente corriente para que puedan
disponer de recursos a través de
nuestros servicios de cripto carteras
digitales
somos después de Turquía el país de
oriente medio con más transacciones de
criptomonedas
el país está sumido en la peor crisis
financiera de su historia si mejores
perspectivas para el futuro y sin
gobierno el Líbano no podrá recibir los
tan necesitados 3.000 millones de
dólares de ayuda del fondo monetario
internacional para el rescate financiero
y los ciudadanos seguirán sin poder
acceder a sus ahorros y en plena fiebre
mundialista el 25 de noviembre se
conmemoraron dos años de la muerte de
Diego Armando Maradona un hecho que tuvo
gran impacto en Italia particularmente
en la ciudad de Nápoles donde el Astro
argentino construyó buena parte de su
carrera Allí se convirtió en el ídolo de
miles y los hinchas lo recordaron con
emoción informe de nuestra corresponsal
Natalia Mendoza
en la periferia de Nápoles se encuentra
un museo particular dedicado a uno de
los deportistas más conocidos del mundo
Diego Armando Maradona aquí máximo viñat
y conserva preciosamente objetos que
pertenecieron al jugador Este es un
zapato especial Porque con este Diego
jugó el Mundial del 86 dos años después
de su muerte El Recuerdo del campeón
argentino sigue intacto para máximo y su
familia sus padres eran amigos
personales de Maradona
Miren esta foto fue el día del
cumpleaños de mi hermana aquí se ve en
Diego mi papá y mi mamá hoy en día mi
mamá cuando lo ve en televisión llora
porque para ella fue como un hijo el
dolor todavía lo sentimos todos los
napolitanos pero para nosotros sigue
vivo porque Maradona es inmortal
una admiración que se siente por toda la
ciudad paseando por Nápoles no es
extraño toparse con gigantografías de
Maradona
en el ajetreado centro histórico esta
Plaza se ha convertido en el punto de
encuentro de los fanáticos del pibe de
oro en este segundo aniversario de su
desaparición el delantero argentino
sigue siendo venerado aquí para nosotros
los napolitanos él es casi una religión
entonces de vez en cuando tenemos que
venir aquí así como otros van a la
iglesia a rezar Nosotros venimos aquí a
rendirle homenaje
Todos aquí recuerdan la espectacular
carrera deportiva de Maradona con el
Napoli en donde jugó entre 1984 y 91
años Durante los cuales el equipo
conquistó los mayores triunfos de su
historia Dos copas de Italia y una copa
europea Maradona cuando Maradona llegó a
Nápoles transformó el grupo en un equipo
importantísimo combatimos a equipos que
en esa época eran inalcanzables para
nosotros y gracias a Maradona logramos
ganarles con Maradona un legado que
inspira hoy en día a toda una nueva
generación de futbolistas en Nápoles que
esperan seguir los pasos del que muchos
consideran el mejor jugador de fútbol de
todos los tiempos
la selección italiana de fútbol no
clasificó al Mundial de Qatar 2022 sin
embargo el país europeo seguirá estando
representado en esta copa de mundial ya
que el ansiado trofeo que la selección
ganadora levantará el próximo 18 de
diciembre fue hecho en lombardía en el
norte del país nuestra corresponsal
Natalia Mendoza nos lleva a conocer los
secretos de su fabricación
esta fábrica situada en los suburbios de
Milán fabrica uno de los premios más
codiciados del mundo el trofeo que se
entregará a los ganadores de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA en Qatar
Este es un trabajo largo y meticuloso es
difícil porque mira la copa tiene un
globo terráqueo en la parte superior
tenemos que Reproducir con exactitud la
geografía con los detalles que quería el
escultor
el escultor que creó el trofeo de 1970
trabajó aquí la copa está hecha
completamente a mano por artesanos como
Pietro ha trabajado en todos los trofeos
desde el Mundial del 98 en Francia me
siento privilegiado por trabajar en esta
copa y para mí es un asunto de familia
mi padre trabajó en esta fábrica por lo
que la habilidad y la experiencia se han
transmitido De Padre A Hijo se necesitan
unas diez personas para fabricar el
trofeo siguiendo un proceso establecido
desde hace mucho tiempo da las funciones
hay que fundir el Metal luego está el
cizallado el tratamiento químico el
esculpido y el Pulido de los contornos
hay toda una serie de etapas por las que
hay que pasar y para tener hay que
trabajar en equipo como un equipo de
fútbol Prácticamente
la última etapa una inmersión química
para eliminar las impurezas Y luego el
chapado en oro de 24 kilates
electromagnética aquí utilizamos ondas
electromagnéticas para pegar las
partículas de oro a la copa la
sumergimos tres o cuatro veces según el
color de la Copa
los ganadores reciben una copia de la
Copa bañada en oro la copa original de
oro macizo solo se utiliza para la
ceremonia de entrega de premios
después de cada mundial original Se
devuelve para su mantenimiento
y se nota que es una copa que se celebra
bien vuelve con marcas manchas y uno que
otro rasguño aquí y allá
50 años después de su creación el trofeo
permanece sin alteraciones a la espera
de ser levantado por el equipo ganador
en Qatar el 18 de diciembre
Muchas gracias al restaurante Merci en
la ciudad de Bogotá por prestarnos sus
instalaciones para la realización de
este programa y a ustedes también Muchas
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en 24 y
24 punto com
[Música]